Junior doctors will follow other health
workers and strike for 72 hours next
month in a dispute overpaid 98 of those
who voted back to the move the British
Medical Association said doctors were
frustrated and angry joined now by the
minister for both mental health and
Women's Health Miracle field hi good
morning thanks for joining us why are 98
of doctors who voted wrong well I'm not
saying they're wrong it's disappointing
absolutely that they voted for strike
action but the BMA specifically on
Junior's doctor pay are asking for
around 26 which is just not affordable
and Junior doctors are in a different
position to other healthcare workers in
that they're not part of the independent
pay review body process they have a
multi-year settlement which was at 8.4
percent when it was last agreed and what
we would what I would say to them is
that we need to get back around the
table in terms of negotiating their next
uh pay settlement because obviously pay
is an issue and Junior doctors cover a
range of doctors from newly qualified
doctors right through to those who are
just about to become consult and so we
do need to obviously want to talk to
them about pay but 26 is not something
that realistically is achievable what is
so that's why we want them to to get
around the table when we did the last
multi-year pay settlement and we settled
at 8.4 you absolutely took on point that
on board their points around pay and
working conditions but strike action is
not going to to resolve this and
particularly concerning is the issue
around them not wanting to cover a e and
things like itu that will have an impact
a serious impact on patients and so I
would say to the BMA come and talk to
the government look at the type of
strike action that they're taking and
you know a multi-year settlement means
that when they agree it when it's a
first delivered that's something that we
can't undo right now the first notice is
that ambulance workers then call workers
now doctors there's a common theme there
and the government's on the wrong side
of this argument well this is impacting
on all four nations where health is
devolved it's you know an issue in Wales
it's an issue in Scotland Northern
Ireland and England so you know we're
not seeing something in England which is
the area I'm responsible for
um that that isn't happening in other
parts of the country so pay is an issue
but you know we have a responsibility to
the taxpayer as well for every one
percent of the pay rise we give that's
700 million pounds we have to find and
we can only find that in one of three
ways we rather have to tax people more
which is something we absolutely do not
want to do rather have to borrow the
money which we saw the impact of doing
that a few months ago when we borrow
more than we can afford all we have to
take out of existing budget and that
means as well you've got um an option as
far as windfall taxes are concerned we
have brought in room for taxes and
they're paying for People's Energy
support right now so people who are
getting uh who have the energy price
guarantee the 400 pounds people are
getting off their energy bills 150
pounds of cancer tax the windfall tax is
being used to pay for that but let's be
clear a windfall tax is not going to pay
for 26 uh increase in pay for junior
doctors
um and I asked you how much you wanted
to offer them and you can't say on live
television I get that um you were a
nurse previously absolutely yeah
how does this sit with you when your
colleagues go on strike for the first
time ever yeah well absolutely I was a
nurse during the pay freeze and the pay
cap which would previously
um had to experience and it is really
difficult
um particularly uh when you the cost of
living is is high at the moment
um so absolutely and I don't think any
nurse uh takes the decision to go on
strike and many nurses uh in England
haven't taken that decision let's be
clear uh you know less than half of
trust in this country have got nurses on
strike but any nurse who goes on strike
it's a very very difficult decision and
they will be torn by doing that but what
and I know Pat um well I have a lot of
respect for Pat Cullen and I would say
to him
absolutely and I would say to her to
give England the same deal as she's
giving Scotland they've called off
strikes in Scotland on based on talks on
pay for this forthcoming Year from April
that's exactly the space that we're in
and I would say to Pat to do the same in
England as she's done in Scotland call
off those strikes and let's see if we
can get a settlement for the forthcoming
years pay award so having previously
been a nurse you know how much they
struggle they don't earn enough money no
absolutely absolutely it is a struggle
and you know no one goes into nursing
not knowing that it's you know the wages
aren't fantastic and people do it
because they love the job and they want
to look after their patients and if I'm
not an MP I'll be go back to to being a
nurse so absolutely I understand uh the
pressures that's being faced but as a
minister I've also got responsible to
the ordinary working people across the
country that have to pay use their taxes
to pay those wages and you know 700
million pounds for every one percent
increase is something I have to justify
in terms of which services that that
money is taken from talk to me about HRT
and the fact that it's going to be
cheaper for women to buy and also what
about those women who can't take it what
are you going to do for them yeah no
absolutely and I think for too long the
menopause the impact on women of the
menopause has been underestimated that
people think it's just simply your
period stopping and a few hot flashes
and for many many women it's a lot more
than that it's debilitating and many
women don't actually really realize
they're going through the menopause
whether it's mood swings whether it's
brain fog whether it's not sleeping
palpitations and we're not talking about
for a few days weeks or months years
that women have to go through this HRT
is one to the choir here
absolutely and you know HRT Works
significantly well in a huge number of
women and we're almost victims of our
own success that we've seen a 50
increase in the number of women taking
HRT and sometimes that does put pressure
on supplies but reducing the cost we do
not want as the government costs to be a
barrier to women starting HRT knowing
the difference that it can make but HRT
isn't for everyone some women don't want
to take it for a variety of reasons they
may be on other health conditions or
medication for some women it doesn't
work despite trying numerous types of
HRT that's some of the concerns yeah and
for some women they get side effects as
well so there are other um kind of
treatments options for HRT as well and
that's why we're setting up what
One-Stop well women clinics across the
country so that women can get expert
advisors Dr as nurses there's
practitioners who are experts in the
menopause and we want women to be able
to access those services so that if HRT
isn't working for them that they have
other options and they can get the help
and advice that they need how helpful is
it that people like Boris Johnson and um
Liz trust almost forgot her name
um
are talking about jets for Ukraine from
the sidelines I mean that's not helpful
is it well I think you know obviously
Boris did a lot for Ukraine in terms of
generating the initial support when the
conflict started but you know Rishi has
been very clear he wants to support
Ukraine further and in fact he's getting
allies from around the world to try and
increase the support that's for you
Craig and he is talking to the defense
secretary Ben Wallace about what planes
could be available but we have to make
sure that these are planes that can be
used relatively quickly what we don't
want is to give them planes that take
months of training for their pilots to
use so those discussions are happening
behind the scenes but absolutely our
full support is behind Ukraine we're
coming up to the year's anniversary on
Friday and there'll be a minute silence
at 11 o'clock to commemorate that around
the country and people can and take some
time out to remember that and the impact
it's having on all our lives and not
just the people of Ukraine but
absolutely those discussions are going
on behind the scenes about how we could
support them further other discussions
going on behind the scenes Northern
Ireland protocol we're going to get a
deal this week I don't know about this
week I know that the prime minister is
working really hard on working with a
number of politicians from across
Northern Ireland politicians within the
EU to try and resolve this the Northern
Ireland protocol isn't working for
Northern Ireland right now and it does
need to be resolved it's a key reason
why there's no functioning assembly in
government in Northern Ireland that's
not great for the people of Northern
Ireland Health who just talked about the
menopause health is a devolved matter in
Northern Ireland what we're introducing
here to reduce costs of hormone
replacement therapy here can't be done
in Northern Ireland at the moment
because there's no functioning
government so it's having a day-to-day
impact on people's lives and it's a key
priority for the Prime Minister let me
squeeze one in very quickly you're a
woman of the world
um Kate Forbes who wants to be the next
first minister in Scotland saying that
she would not have backed same-sex
marriage 1970s on the phone well you
know that's a matter for the s p to
decide who they want to be there the
next leader look I'm personally uh
supportive of equal marriage I voted for
it actually for Northern Ireland the
last time their assembly was out
um and Westminster had to take that
decision but it is a matter for the s p
and then it'll be a matter for the
people of Scotland where they decide
that the leader that they then have is
someone they want to continue with great
to see you thanks very much for joining
us thank you